we mentioned it earlier but going back
to 2012 omega dr ended up winning the
Soul Calibur 5 World Championship and
that was a real ya wit nightmare but
this time playings ass is awesome all
pretty I I don't know if we would say
the strongest [ __ ] no but absolutely
out there for sure and I mean he's
already turned it up through this LCQ
being in the winner side of top 16 here
but same it has has been touted by many
a different person to be probably the
favorite to make it through the elbows
into the top eight it's it's a it's a
hard draw honestly to compress the same
for literally anybody in the bracket
even those that have already been
invited yeah I mean st. has proven
himself time and again like throughout
so many different events tournaments
everyone here knows his strengths so
that can I mean that could prove to be
go against them as well I mean people
know his tendencies they know his insane
ability his reflexes who knows the
hottest most recent winners the kumite
in taxes one yeah
as Omega they are the last thing he was
at in America was the Texas showdown
which was way earlier of the year yeah
so that's the he does have that to his
benefit
he's not as well-traveled as these other
players maybe a bit harder to keep tabs
on him plus plus he has the heart of a
champion you got to remember that we've
got these that the beauty of online
means the Internet
you don't always have to make the
traveler just so long as you are you
study very strongly right yeah so again
we're talking about two characters that
are very very strong at the range
matchup due to the fact that they have
very far-reaching moves but however is a
slim it was a card too that pulls you in
right and a lot of the time IV players
will like to prey upon vacuuming to
sneak in those command grabs right
because like she kind of she kind of
sucks
under right before doing their commands
forcing the player to play her rage
right or folly to rage that's the first
one how many are we gonna see from
saying this is the bread and butter I'd
like to say we'd see 12 okay yeah so uh
one thing I want to talk about is a mega
the iron you one of the few players to
use that 3k you likes it a lot on you
know on on counter here you do get 460
afterwards then if you have a curse time
stop combo it's the free damage followed
here they do it in same job right now
for six beam here we go with set up
afterwards okay to beat yeah it's a
vacuuming effect right so he's gonna get
the back row here and one chance for
saying to be able to block to a [ __ ]
for the pressure and there it is gonna
close it out and take that first round
same with the spacing oh man that was
great oh there it is that's the first my
sword for saying so you don't watch that
OBC when that when he starts busting out
the my sword cancels
that's when you know he's feeling
himself the more often he does it yeah
packing up right there I'll make it the
arm plays [ __ ] know who's currently
considered probably to be the best
reversal ring out character i've used to
probably be it before the nurse but you
know SAS has taken the throne nice combo
here pushing again towards the wall
gonna have to watch that nice big sweep
and again is that gonna push out i think
that's just going
oh yeah it was kids oh look at that -
round two very nice round therefore safe
clutch Eddy
each time a negative buddy there's the
to eight to go under the command so
catching him out of the sea yeah
you wasted all that meter there right
now Omega dr with slight life advantage
but also the meter this is big
that seems able to capitalize and do
something you probably get on the score
of all why I'm breaking ball thank you a
pressure there it is okay okay that's
negative but he stopped yeah and that's
the thing is sometimes players have to
do the unexpected they're putting the
negative state but they're still attack
so pressing but I think SAS Allah knows
actually what it all fourths in by side
stepping into the sea and that's gonna
be great for saying is you should be
able to make it on the rig out anytime
first game no round brown that's the
thing it was three straight rounds but
it always came down to the end it always
came down the end but man st. able to
come out on top each time yeah so one of
the things that same did there right was
with a very common tactic forces a slim
L is due to the nerfs to see it's his
he's very very fine stuff right so a lot
of the times you'll be if the person has
just a lot of meter they'll just kind of
walk up to him and then decide some fun
right yeah and so you just caught up on
that now coming into the second game are
you with the command throw recurse right
there for gospel yeah that's the big is
like you know sometimes that's a no
players will want to throw it up just
because it's saved oh my gosh can I get
a precursor here though yeah nice talk
yeah 3a k and 3 AP is normally all the
unblockable setup okay drop the leg
that's huge leg up there yeah you got it
represented a couple of times right I'm
sure it's escapable bday if you don't
show them oh god popping a flame trap
there but yeah that's the thing you got
to put the beards all right you got a
little bill that it's there that you're
gonna go for it
that is neutral on block on the full
chart hey there it is 46 beat just
persistent with it you know we tried to
make it work there no duck that time
let's see with you this year again try
to pull up Edwards yeah I mean you know
maybe I was trying to play the Pope game
that's ounces normally about that you
know with the 383 aks but up until just
now it wasn't really working out there's
the 6 6 B to be able to catch them out
of the air and to round straight I'll
make it the art with a statement yeah he
is trying to change this real quick
you get three rounds I'll get three
rounds oh oh yeah he attempted to do the
same thing to bait out or maybe the RCE
Hager was ready for it this time give me
that snap baby yeah just I'm getting
some extra damage out of it let's see
what he does here you get a pressure
right by the wall creates tons forcing
this whole truck stood atop the wall
doesn't want to deal with that damage
right this is big too cuz he's gonna do
a lot of damage getting beat amazing
position tournaments done
oh no no ever thought it was one curse
what if it was two it would have been
done yeah so he actually got a tech
trapped right there into the four six
beat so that's why he stood up into it
but he only had the one first we
couldn't finish it off still regardless
get the game it's one-to-one right very
very tight range tech roll catch here
but that was an impressive display of
skill there from whoa mega dr geez now
we'll go to our final match also that
was pork a lethal my bad
oh but still able to get the sex off
that in a ton of damage okay untouchable
throw here it's the set up afterwards 2
to 8 G's yeah back to back command grabs
they're able to get a lot of damages
because it is to see what he does with
it no I like that he's just backing up
right he's just gonna take the
opportunities for Omega D Ardo to hang
himself because a lot of the time he had
been using negative attacks up until
that throw another negative attack their
Christmas tree comes out that's
something we haven't really seen st.
using too much the season card damage
yeah but then there it is first-round
the same those over a hard-fought first
row for both of these players and again
couple grab right there regardless of
the card damages autumn on the way back
up two in a row back to back and gets
the big lunch afterwards great Oki wants
you to do good block there on the low
it's gonna salt charge to be able to get
offensive pressure right back right it's
not like Oh make it the other has a bar
it's a sole charge but he gets the
lethal in six BB oh yeah and he gets the
ball up with the combo here let's see
what he's doing wake up here we go one a
pressure but it's a lazy attack I like
that he didn't want to deal with that oh
well I'm stepping though on the 3a he's
gonna have to be careful of well throws
out the beater you might as well do it
early on right oh the lady had no charge
but the problem wasn't because it was
off axis they gave maple as B instead of
a ta plus B he's gonna have an
opportunity here pulls him in oh boy he
lost he tried to break his guard with
the back turn B because it was that red
right he got greedy and of course Satan
a little bit patient there was able to
capitalize and take that around oh my
god they're untouchable look at that he
is trying to expand here he wants to run
away with this again yeah he was really
deep too and it was a ball okay let's
see what he does throwing it out
oh man four people escaped not the tech
trap though he's got three curses big
damage as possible yeah hey fix Oh baby
with things you have to be careful here
oh yeah dev ducked cuz I feel like you
probably would have broke him there
anyways yeah either way either way that
is big for Omega D are getting on the
scoreboard here and he still has all
this meter to that he's gonna be able to
utilize it the rest of this match okay
finally the cria be right there to do
some card damage
hey six actually gets tucked under there
feel my gosh thanks sole charge they
gone for two DS here for both of these
players but again flashing red oh my
gosh that time he waited for SAS lamell
to autocorrects late he did not get the
other sort of it what's he gonna do here
the race and that's gonna do it feign
taking it over Omega CR he's all smiles
now Omega D are moving into the loser's
bracket and say moving on into our top
eight side oh what a battle between
those two able to take down the previous
one that was like long time ago yeah I
mean it's everybody had gigantic hopes
for saying especially coming into this
so I it's it's not exactly super
far-fetched that most people expected
him to do very very well and oh yeah
I'll make it the aren't put up a goddamn
fight that was quite the fight I mean
the battles went back and forth I mean
he brought it especially in that second
match but and then the third match it
all came down to the end and Sain was a
but let out every single time a lot of
the commandos it just really set the
tone for each one of those rounds or
that he was able to pull off
back-to-back whether it was command
throw untenable it was just insane yeah
and I mean you know especially because
the the tuckable ones is done more
damage but yeah you toss in a couple of
those untouchable ones and it's also by
the way really really hard to tech the
tech ofwell command throw from IVs it's
just throwing that out there